Russia is ramping up its retaliation
against the US over new sanctions
Russian President Vladimir Putin told
the US yesterday to slash its staff in
Russia by 755 people his order comes in
response to expanded sanctions passed by
Congress Elizabeth Palmer
is in Moscow with the simmering tensions
that have cold war echoes Liz good
morning good morning
the State Department has called this
Russian action regrettable and uncalled
for but the Russians are saying they had
no choice but to react to the tightening
of sanctions against them all weekend
does the world waited President Putin
didn't say a word about Russia's
retaliation against the u.s. he was busy
with the pomp of Russia's Navy Day a
celebration and also a reminder that
Russian muscle extends out over the
oceans to finally on Sunday evening he
weighed in the American diplomatic
mission in Russia he said would have to
lose 755 personnel we waited for quite
some time for something to change for
the battery said referring to relations
with Washington but it became clear it
wouldn't be soon the State Department
won't reveal how many people it employs
but the Russians say there are 1,200 in
Moscow and three other cities two-thirds
of them will have to be cut so the
American diplomatic operation is trimmed
to the same size as Russia's mission in
the u.s. the US will also lose access to
a storage facility and it's beautiful
country house and leafy property on the
outskirts of Moscow this is the latest
round in a tit-for-tat deterioration of
relations between the Trump
administration and the Kremlin which
began last Thursday when Congress voted
to extend sanctions against Russia and
on Friday the Russians hit back and then
hinted Russia may not be done with
retaliation we have a very rich toolbox
at our disposal it would be ridiculous
on my part to start speculating on what
may or may not happen there is no
confirmation yet but it does look as if
the vast
majority of those 755 people who are
going to lose their jobs will be
Russians locally hired to work in
support of American programs everything
from trade and commerce to agriculture
Charlie
Elizabeth palm in Moscow thanks to those